تشهد الخرطوم برعايه من الامم المتحده
ومجموعه ايجاد والرباعيه المرحله النهائيه
للعمليه السياسيه الراميه لانهاء الازمه
السودانيه تتضمن هذه المرحله مشاورات بين
المدنيين والعسكريين والموقعين على اتفاق
الاطار السياسي ستركز تله اربعه ايام على
خمس قضايا بينها تفكيك نظام البشير بهدف
التوصل الى خرائط الطريق لحلها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبرتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابرز القضايا التي
ستركز عليها مشاورات المرحله النهائيه
والتي تاتي بعد مرور شهر على توقيع
الاتفاق الاداري العمليات السياسيه ما هي
التحديات التي تواجهها هذه المرحله وكيف
يمكن تجاوزها وما هي معاني وخريطه الطريق
التي يمكن ان تفرزها نتائج المشاورات
النهائيه حول كل القضايا وكيف سينعكس هذا
الاتفاق على مستقبل البلاد في مختلفه
المجالات لا سيما الاوضاع المعيشيه
لسودانيين والحريه
[موسيقى]
الى مرحله النهائيه من المشاورات وصل قطار
الازمه في السودان باحثا عن نهايه لها وهي
التي كانت قد اشتدت منذ اعلان الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان اجراءات استثنائيه اعتبرها
معارضوها انقلابا على ديمقراطيه في الشوط
الرهن من العمليه السياسيه وبحثات بين
المكون العسكري واطراف مدنيه وقعت على
اتفاق الاطار السياسي محورها خمس قضايا
تبحث عن خرائط طريق لحلها من بين اهمها
تفكيك ما تبقى من نظام عمر البشير
والعداله الانتقاليه واصلاح المنظومتين
الامنيه والعسكريه ويبقى الرهان الاكبر
للمسار المدعوم من قبل الامم المتحده
والرباعيه ومجموعه ايجاد استماره قوى
بدنيه ترفضه وتراه قفزا فوق يستحقاقات
الضروريه لتحولا ديمقراطيا حقيقي حقيقي
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم كل من
محمد عبد الحكم القيادي بالحريه والتغيير
مجموعه المجلس المركزي مصطفى طنبور
القيادي بالحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه واللواء معتصم الحسن الاستاذ
السابق في الاكاديميه العليا لدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بكم جميع
ضيوفنا سنبدا معك لواء معتصم الحسن هل
التوصل الى حسن في كل هذه القضايا
المطروحه اليوم في اطار هذه المشاورات من
العمليات السياسيه هل التوصل الى حسن
بشانها محسوم
انا لا اعتقد ذلك انا اعتقد ان هذه
القضايا لن يتم نقاشها لان الاطراف جميع
قضايا الخمسه غائبه اولا قضيه الشرق
القطاعات العظمى من الشرق بقياده الناظر
ترك رافدا للاتفاق الايطالي
كذلك القوه الرئيسيه في سلام جوبا رافضه
للاتفاق الاطاري مساله اصلاح
والقوات المسلحه والنظاميه هذه قضيه
عسكريه فنيه بحته كذلك هي خارج النقاش
ايضا موضوع العداله
الانتقاليه هذه مساله قضائيه وقانونيه
وكذلك تفكيك نظام 30 يونيو هذه مساله
قضائيه وقانونيه خصوصا بعد الفشل الذري
الذي جابهته اللجنه السابقه والاجراء غير
القانونيه وغير
وغير الدستوريه التي اتخذت اتخذتها اتجاه
ليس همم اقطاب النظام السابق وانما كذلك
تجاه مواطنين ومستثمرين ابرياء لا علاقه
لهم بنظام 30 يونيو انا اعتقد ان اا مثل
هذه الاحتفالات ومثل هذه الخطب لن تجدي في
غياب العناصر الاساسيه التي يمكن ان تساهم
في اداره الحوار
لماذا تنعقد هذه المشاورات
انا اعتقد ان هذه المشاورات خاصه بطرف
معين دون الاطراف الاخرى هنالك طرف صادر
حريه الاخرين وصادر حقهم في المشاركه في
اداره وحكم البلاد ويحاول ان ياتي بهم
معصوبي الاعين ومكتفي الايدي للتوقيع على
اتفاقته تلك القوه التي وقعت على الاتفاق
الايطالي وانا اعتذر
انا اقصد ان المجلس المركزي يحاول ان
يستفرد بالسلطه دون الاخرين وهذه المساله
لن تحل المشكله اطلاقا اما ما يخص الجانب
العسكري الجانب العسكري يوافق تماما على
المدنيه السلطه وعلى تسليمها للقوه التي
سوف ينتقبها الشعب في المرحله القادمه
في حقيقه الامر ما ادلى به ضيفك الاخر هو
الترهات لا علاقه لها بالحقائق على الارض
همم الحديث عن اختطاف وعن همم كابتن
الحريات هذه الجهات ثابته تلقى دوما على
العاهن من قبل هذه المجموعه التي اعلن حتى
الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه بانها
همم غير مسؤوله عنها وتمثل اراها الشخصيه
الان قاطره العمليه السياسيه التمضي
بثلاثه ووصلت واحده من المحطات الاخيره
للوصول لحل نهائي للازمه في ال- في
السودان هذه الازمه محدد للضروره اطرافها
ومحدد طبيعتها الاطراف فيه الاطراف
السوريه التي جابت الانقلاب وقومته وناضلت
من اجل اجتماع المسار الثوره ومسار
الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي
هذه القوه الموجوده الان اا والتي ااه
بذلت واطلقت العمليه السياسيه برعايه اميه
وبشهود من كل المجتمع الدولي والاقليمي
تعلم تماما وتعيي بان النقاشات عميقه يجب
ان تجرح حول قضايا اساسيه مهمه تعني كل
مواطن في السودان وتعني بالضروره الحلفاء
السودان
يقول ان معظم هذه القضايا المطروحه لن يتم
الوصول الى حسن بشانها لان من يفترض ان
يحسن بشانها غائب عن هذا عن هذه المشاورات
هو حديث طبعا المرسل وغير صحيح
اولا الان نحن نتحدث مثلا الورشه التي
ستعقد ابتداء من التاسعه صباحا يوم غد
ستعقد عن تفكيك تمكين نظام 30 من يونيو
هذه الورشه سيحضر فيها عناصر اللجنه
المجمده وسنحضر ايضا خبراء وقانونين
بامكانهم اطفاء همم مزيد من من الضوء على
ما يجب ان يفعل في الفتره المقبله بعد
الخلاص الى اتفاق نهائي كيفيه
مزاوله اللجنه للنشاطه مره اخرى
باستنادا على قوانين همم ستوضع وفقا
لتصورات المناقشين هنالك نقاشات عميقه فقط
الحديث عن ان هذه الورش لم تاتي كلها ولم
تاتي بمخرجات جديده هو ربما يعني ضرب
للرمل او الرمي للوجه همم محاولات للتنبؤ
الان هنالك وليست
فينتظر حتى يرى مخرجات هذه الورش ومن ثم
يحدد موقفه منها لا يمكن ان يكون الموقف
مسبقا
الان هذه المحاولات مستمتيه لتعطيه المسار
العمليه السياسيه وسوف تنبور باعتقادك هل
العمليه السياسيه ستجري بثلاثه هذه المره
وسيتم الحسم بشان كل هذه الامور المطروح
شكرا جزيلا وفي البدء انا اهنئ الشعب
السوداني العظيم همم مناسبه عيد الاستقلال
المجيد واتمنى ان يكون هذا العام عاما
للاستقرار وعمل للسلام وعمل للتحول الكامل
اا ويعود الشعب السوداني امنا مستقرا في
دولته السودانيه همم اسمح لي اولا اختي
العزيزه نقطه في غايه الاهميه وهي ان
العمليه السياسيه التي ظللنا نتحدث عن
اهميتها ولفترات طويله جدا حتى هذه اللحظه
لم تبتدا بعد الكل يعلم ان الذي يجري الان
هو فقط محاولات يائسه من الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي لتضليل الراي العام
السوداني ان هذه العمليه هي عمليه شامله
اه هو جامعه لكل الاطراف اما يدور الان هو
عباره
مصطفى يتم برعايته امنيه في ر مجموعه
الايجاد همم والرباعيه الافريقيه الموضوع
لا يخص فقط مجموعه المجلس المركزي في قوى
الحريه والتغيير وانما مسار سياسي انخرطت
فيه العديد من القوى السياسيه انتم لم
توقعوا على هذا الاتفاق الايطالي ما اسباب
ذلك
يا سيدتي ليس الامر وجود الامم المتحده او
الايجاد او الاتحاد الافريقي او غيرها من
الجهات الدوليه المهم همم في نظرنا هو
توافق الشعب السوداني همم
وتحركه مجتمعين حول تسويه سياسيه شامله
تنقذ البلاد من الازمه الكبيره التي ظل
يعيشها طيله الفترات السابقه نحن لم نوقع
على الاتفاق الاطار المزعوم ولدينا تحفظات
واضحه ان هذا الاتفاق الاطار هو اتفاق
صممته جهه معروفه وهي المجلس المركزي
للحريه والتغيير دون سواها وبالتالي نحن
لم نكن مستوى ثاني في هذا الاتفاق او في
اي اتفاق اخر يمكن ان يجمع بقيه الكتل
السياسيه التي لم توقع نحن شخصنا الازمه
السودانيه
ملاحظاتنا واضحه
صور واضحه يعني ما البدائل التي قدمتموها
على هذا الاتفاق وانت تعلم ان الازمه
السياسيه كانت وصلت في السودان الى حدود
الانسداد نحن لدينا يا سيدتي تصور كامل
لمعالجه الازمه السياسيه السودانيه
الراهنه ونحن سلمناها لجهات الدوليه
وسلمناها لك كثير من القوه السياسيه
الحريصه على التوافق الوطني والحريص على
التسويه السياسيه الشامله التي لا تستثني
سوى المؤتمر الوطني الذي لفظه الشعب
السوداني عندما انتصر لثورته التراكمي في
ديسمبر وبالتالي نحن لم نقبل اي اتفاق او
اي تسويه تفرط من اي جهه كانت ليس لاي جهه
الحق في ان تملي ارادتها على الاخرين نحن
شركاء في هذا الوطن ولدينا حقنا في تناول
الازمات السودانيه والابداع بالاراءنا
بشكل كامل ومستقي الان نحن بصدد هذه
العمليه السياسيه حاليا
باعتقادك ام وجهه نظر الكتله الديمقراطيه
الى اين ستفضي هذا هذا المسار السياسي الى
اين سوف هذه
الذي يجري الان هو محاوله
للقفز على الخطوات الاساسيه التي يمكن ان
تساعدنا جميعا في احتواء هذه الازمه وهي
ضروره ان يجلس السودانيون اولا وان
يتوافقوا حولي اا
اا مائده مستديره لنقاش هذه الازمه
السياسيه المستفحله جدا وبالتالي ما يدور
الان في النهايه لا يفضي الى شيء سوى
تحقيق رغبه الذين صمموا هذا الاتفاق
الاطاري همم باستثناء بقيه الشعب السوداني
وقواه السياسيه والسوريه الحيه ان تتعلم
جيدا ان الشارع الان لم يتوقف مسيره ال-
ال- ال- ال- الاحتياجات تتصاعد بشكل يومي
هنالك احزاب سياسيه تاريخيه لديها حتى
الان خارج هذا الاتفاق الاطاري هنالك
حركات مسليه
اكثر من 19 عاما هي خارج هذا الاتفاقا
اللواء معتصم الحسن وان نحن نتحدث في اطار
هذه الحلقه همم مستمره همم
شورات الجاريه في الخرطوم تحدث قبل قليل
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقال ان هناك تطلع لحكومه مدنيه تحقق
تطلعات الشعب السوداني
باعتقادك هل سيتحقق هذا ولماذا يعني
سيختلف ما سينتج عن هذه المشاورات عما نتج
في المرات السابقه
يثبت نقطه اساسيه نحن عندما نتحدث مثل هذه
المناظر في الجزيره وغيرها من المنابر
الاخرى نتحدث بصفاتنا نعبر ونحلل في
الاحداث ولا نتحدث بصفاتنا العاشق عن اي
قوى نظاميه هذه المساله واضحه وانتم تدعون
لنا بهذه الصفه انا اعتقد ان هذه المساله
محسومه مساله همم حديث السيد البرهان انا
اعتقد ان هذا التزام منذ 2019 ان القوه
همم في مرحله ما ستسلم عاجل كما ذكر عاجلا
ام عاجلا ستسلم الى القوى المدنيه وكما
ذكر ان المؤسسه العسكريه في بصيغه معينه
بصيغه معينه نفسيه
هذه المره
بالنظر الى ما حصل في المره السابقه
والاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي اتخذها
البرهان واعتبرت في حينها من قوى الثوره
على انها انقلاب لماذا لن يتكرر هذا الامر
باعتقادك هذه المره
ليس هنالك ضمان لاخضاع المؤسسه العسكريه
والقوات النظاميه لاي قوى مدنيه غير
منتخبه هذه المساله مفروغ منها لذلك على
مجلس المركزي اذا اراد حكم السودان بقواه
المدنيه ان يحكمه مع القوه الاخرى في هذه
المرحله الانتقاليه واي شركه القوه الاخرى
سواقه كانت قوه جهويه من اتفاق جوبا او
قوى شرق السودان او القوه السياسيه الاخرى
الموجوده على الساحه هنالك الان قوى
سياسيه اعلنت رفضها لهذا الاتفاق ولهذه
المشاورات قبل ان تبدا هنالك التغيير
الجذري اعلنا رفضه هنالك نداء السودان
وهنالك كيان الشرق الذي اعلن رفضه لذلك
انا اعتقد ان حتى القوه الاجنبيه او القوه
التي تريد مساعده السودانيين في امرهم
الامر في النهايه يعود الى السودانين
سيد محمد عبد الحكم اذا كما قال اللواء
معتصم الحسن لا ضامن لتسليم السلطه رغم ما
ينص عليه الاتفاق الاتاري سوى الى قوى
مدنيه منتخبه على اي اساس اذا انخرتهم في
هذه العمليه السياسيه
الوصول لحكومه منتخبه في الاساسي يحتاج
الى فتره الانتقال نحن الان في فتره
انقلابيه قبلها كنا في فتره الانتقاليه
للوصول لديمقراطيه والتصويت الشعب
السوداني على من يحكمه لم يستطيع التوصل
بسبب انزلاق 25 اكتوبر ولكن بسالت ومقاومه
الشعب السوداني همم الكبير جدا اجبر
الانجلاديين على الركول الى المطالب
الرئيسه المطالب بها شارع السوداني هذه
الادوات التي جربها الشعب السوداني طويلا
هي موجوده بامكانها مره اخرى ان يعيد ذات
تتحدث عنها
الاكبر على المكون العسكري معظمها اليوم
غير موقع وغير موافق على هذه العمليه
السياسيه حتى ان بعضها كالجان المقاومه
يدعو الى تظاهرات في الشارع غدا
ليس اكثرها للدقه اغلب الشعب السوداني
بمكونات المجتمعيه وهو دائم للاتفاق
الايطالي الللل المجمع الصوفي العام جماعه
الانصار السنه المحمديه الادارات الاهليه
عدد كبير جدا من الفعاليات الاجتماعيه على
المستوى السوداني هي دائما للاتفاق
الايطالي فيما عدا بعض المستفيدين من بقاء
الانقلاب كما هو عليه الحال والبعض
الرافدين اساسا لنبدا التحول المدني
الديمقراطيين الى حكم عسكري ابديه وهذا
همم ما لا يمكن لاي حال من الاحوال ان
يسمح به كقوه سوريه لا بد من استعاده
التحول ومساراته ولابد من الوصول الى حكم
الى ديمقراطي حقيقي على الانتخابات حقيقيه
عبر مرحله للانتقال لان كما تعلمين سيدتي
الوصول للانتخابات يحتاج اقله الى امين من
اجل هذه القوى
يعني سيد محمد هذه القوى الرافده تتحدث عن
تداعيات كبيره ل اا الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
التي اتخذها المكونه العسكري في المرحله
الماضيه تداعيات سياسيه تداعيات امنيه
تداعيات متعلقه بالارواح التي دفعت همم
ثمنا لهذا الاعتراض على ما حدث اين كل ذلك
في هذه العمليه السياسيه الجاريه الان
كل
كل القضايا التي تهمه الشعب السوداني الان
هي في محور النقاشات الورش والمؤتمرات
التي
ابتديت اليوم وستتواصل في الايام المقبله
بما فيها قضايا العداله من الشهداء ليس
فقط شهداء ثوره ديسمبر ولكن كل من اجري في
حقه منذ 30 يوم 1989
حول اليات وكيفيات الوصول لعداله همم لكل
هذه الجمله التي تمت في حق الشعب السعودي
يعني كل القضايا الاخرى المتعلقه بتفكيك
بنيه النظام السابق سواء همم
المسارات التي كانت موجوده على مستوى
اتفاق سلام السودان في جوبا اسال عن
المجمع همم قضيه شرق السودان هذه القضايا
جميعها واهم القضايا ايضا اصلاح همم
المنظومه الامنيه في السودان
اذا تحدث عن انه ليس هنالك لان المؤسسه
العسكريه المؤسس العسكريه نحن نعلم بانها
طب على الاطلاق في ان تسلم السلطه
المدنيين المجموعات واستفاده
اجتماعيا
ما هذه العمليه السياسيه بصدد معالجته هي
القضايا الاساسيه التي خرج من اجلها الناس
الشعب السوداني الذي نعرفه ونحن ااا جزء
كبير همم من الكتل السياسيه او من القوه
السياسيه التي تمثلها الشعب السوداني
قضاياه واضحه جدا وهي ليست القضايا التي
يتحدث عنها ضيفك الذي تفضل بالحديث قبل
قليل وبالتالي انا اعتقد مواصله الشعب
السوداني لنضالاته في الشارع عبر
المظاهرات وعبر المسيرات المتقرره وعمر
الاعتصامات والضغط ال-
اغلب القوى التي ضغطت في الشارع في خلال
المرحله الماضيه موافقه واغلب السودانيين
موافقين على هذا المساء
غير صحيح هذا الحديث غير صحيح تماما ولا
يستند على اي منطقه سليم الشعب السوداني
حتى الان الرافد لهذا الاتفاق الاطار
الثنائي وقال قوله عندما نزل الى الشارع
في مسير الضخمه جدا وحتى يوم غدا كما
تفضلت قبل قليل سيخرج الشعب السوداني في
تظاهره كبيره جدا لهذا الاتفاق الاطار
الثنائي
والتغيير
مجموعه المجلس المركزي وشكرا للواء معتصم
الحسن الاستاذ السابق في الاكاديميه
العليا للدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
ضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من الخرطوم الى هنا
مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم اليك
[موسيقى]